WITH
PUBLIC IMPEACHMENT HEARINGS.
THE ONE HERE NOW, CONGRESSMAN
DEVIN NUNES AND THE OTHER OF
WHICH ON, GREGG JARRETT.
WE ALREADY KNOW THAT THE PROCESS
IS FLAWED BECAUSE AT THE END OF
THE DAY, CONGRESSMAN, IS IT TRUE
OR NOT TRUE THAT ADAM SCHIFF WAS
COMPROMISED IN THIS CASE.
HE GETS DENIED THE WITNESSES YOU
CALL, HE GETS TO MAKE THE FINAL
DECISION ON EVERYTHING, DOESN'T
HE?
SO THERE REALLY ARE NO RIGHTS BY
THE RANKING MEMBERS OF THE
PRESIDENT AND HIS ATTORNEYS.
>> AS YOU KNOW, NOBODY LIKES TO
DISAGREE WITH RUSH LIMBAUGH BUT
I THINK IN THIS CASE, RUSH
LIMBAUGH ONLY HAS IT ABOUT HALF
RIGHT.
AT LEAST DURING THE CAVANAUGH
HEARINGS, THE REPUBLICANS HAD
THE ABILITY TO BRING UP PEOPLE
WHO WERE REPORTING STOMACH
SUPPORTING CAVANAUGH.
WE DON'T EVEN HAVE THAT SO
ADAM SCHIFF AND HIS TEAM,
HOWEVER, MET WITH THERE WITH A
WHISTLE-BLOWER, WE HAVE HAD NO
ACCESS TO THE WHISTLE-BLOWER.
NEVER CHUCKLE, WE WANT TO KNOW
WHAT WAS THE DNC'S INVOLVEMENT
IN THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN AND THE
INVOLVEMENT IN UKRAINE AND WHY
DID THE UKRAINIANS INTERFERE INO
DID THE UKRAINIANS INTERFERE INR
ELECTION?
WELLS I HAVE OUT OF THE
SITUATION WITH HUNTER BIDEN, HOW
DID HE GET 80,000 SOMETHING
DOLLARS A MONTH?
THESE ARE JUST QUESTIONS WE
DESERVE TO HAVE THE ANSWER TO
YOU BEFORE ANY OF THE CIRCUS IS
SET TO BEGIN ON WEDNESDAY.
WE SHOULD HAVE THOSE ANSWERS.
>> Sean: YOU HAVE A LIST OF
PEOPLE, INCLUDING ADAM SCHIFF,
THE WHISTLE-BLOWER, NELLIE OHR,
HUNTER BIDEN, JOE BIDEN, WILL
ANY OF YOUR WITNESSES BE ALLOWED
TO TESTIFY?
>> AS OF RIGHT NOW, WE HAVE NONE
OF OUR WITNESSES.
LOOK, WE EVEN PUT ON -- THE NEW
FOLDER.
THIS GUY WAS THE DEMOCRATS FIRST
WITNESS BUT HE CAME IN, IT
DIDN'T GO VERY WELL FOR THEM, HE
CAME INVOLUNTARILY, THE
TRANSCRIPT OR HOW, WHY ON EARTH
WOULD VOLKER NOT BE THERE
QUESTION MONKEY WAS THE SPECIAL
ENVOY TO UKRAINE.
WE ARE HAVING THE TOP PEOPLE AT
THE STATE DEPARTMENT AND THE
HANDLE UKRAINE AND NOW THE
ACTING AMBASSADOR THAT IS COMING
IN ON WEDNESDAY, WHY WOULD YOU
NOT HAVE VOLKER ON THE STAINED
PANEL?
WHY WOULD YOU NOT GIVE THE
REPUBLICANS A WITNESS?
AS OF RIGHT NOW TILL WE HAVE NO
WITNESSES AND WE HAVE NO
KNOWLEDGE OF THE FOUNDATION OF
THIS CASE AND OF THESE
ACCUSATIONS.
>> Sean: FUNDAMENTALLY, LIKE
EVERYTHING ELSE, YOU OUTLINED
THIS IN BOTH OF YOUR BOOKS,
GREGG JARRETT, EVERYTHING
BOOMERANGS BACK.
THE ONLY RUSSIAN INTERFERENCE WE
KNOW OF WAS THE DOSSIER.
IT'S A LITTLE IRONIC.
NOW UKRAINE ELECTION
INTERFERENCE, THAT'S THE
DEMOCRATS AND THE ONLY QUID PRO
QUO WAS HUNTER BIDEN COME YOU
GET THE BILLION IF YOU FIRE THE
GUY INVESTIGATING MY SON, YOU
DON'T GET THE BILLION OTHERWISE.
>> IF THIS WERE AN EQUITABLE
PROCESS, BOTH SIDES WOULD BE
ABLE TO CALL THEIR OWN WITNESSES
BUT ADAM SCHIFF WON'T ALLOW IT.
HE CAN ONLY AND WILL ONLY ALLOW
WITNESSES THAT HE LIKES.
IT REMINDS ME OF THE OLD HENRY
FORD QUOTE, ANY CUSTOMER CAN
HAVE A CAR PAINTED ANY COLOR AS
LONG AS IT'S BLACK.
LOOK AT THE FIRST TWO WITNESSES
THAT WILL BE CALLED ON
WEDNESDAY, BILL TAYLOR AND
GEORGE SCOTT.
THEY ADMIT THEY HAVE NO DIRECT
KNOWLEDGE OF A QUID PRO QUO AND
INSTEAD THEY HEARD IT FROM A GUY
WHO HEARD IT FROM A GUY WHO
HEARD IT FROM AN ORIGINAL GUY
AND IN BOTH CASES, IT IS
DIPLOMAT, GORDON SONDLAND.
LONG-WINDED ADMITS HE HAS NO
DIRECT KNOWLEDGE OF THE QUID PRO
QUO AND INSTEAD HE TESTIFIED HEP
QUO AND INSTEAD HE TESTIFIED HEE
QUO AND INSTEAD HE TESTIFIED HEU
QUO AND INSTEAD HE TESTIFIED HED
IT SO THIS IS OPINION BUILT
ON HEARSAY CONSTRUCTED ON
SPECULATION AND CONJECTURE E.
>> Sean: THE SENATE,
CONGRESSMAN NEW KNOWS, THEY HAVE
THE ABILITY TO CALL ALL OF THESE
WITNESSES.
LINDSEY GRAHAM SAID THIS IS DEAD
ON ARRIVAL WITHOUT THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER AND HE WANTS
HUNTER BIDEN TO TESTIFY.
TELL US WHAT THE SENATE CAN DO
AND WHAT WOULD YOU RECOMMEND
THEY DO?
>> LET'S SEE HOW THIS GOES THIS
WEEK.
MY GUESS IS IT'S GOING TO BE A
COMPLETE CIRCUS PAID WE ARE NOT
GOING TO GET ANY OF OUR
WITNESSES, THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA
IS GOING TO SAY HOW DAMAGING IT
IS TO THE PRESIDENT.
IF THAT IS JUST GOING TO BE THE
STORY LINE FOR THE FACT OF THE
MATTER IS, IF YOU ACTUALLY READ
THE TRANSCRIPT AND GREGG JARRETT
WAS JUST GOING THROUGH THEM,
BYRON YORK HAS A PIECE OUT
TONIGHT TALKING ABOUT THEIR STAR
WITNESS, THESE TRANSCRIPTS, AS
WE WERE SAYING WHEN THE
DEMOCRATS WERE SLOWLY LEAKING
THESE OUT TO THE FRIENDS OF THE
MEDIA, THAT'S WHAT WE'VE BEEN
DOING FOR THE LAST SIX WEEKS,
BUT ON THE TRANSCRIPTS ARE OUT,
THEY ARE DEVASTATING TO
DEMOCRATS SO LET'S SEE WHERE IT
GOES BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY,